Now I want to show all of you a classic example of a pinhole photograph.
Here is one and
you notice that very interesting things are happening in this one.
All lines are straight.
There is no form of distortion.
Also if you look at it, the whole image is, has infinite depth.
That has everything is in focus.
This is a pinhole where there is no lens whatsoever.
Basically somebody built a box, put a small hole in it,
and put a film or a censor on the other end and generated this image.
Actually it looks pretty nice.
And basically what's important is there is no form of blurring,
no de-focus artifacts, and each and
every line if you were to draw it, would appear completely straight.
Of course when we start going over from pinhole cameras,
we'll notice that we will be compromising on these types of
perfect capabilities that a pinhole camera might have.